for the first time we were hearing from
the woman who made headlines around the
world for giving voice to sexual assault
survivors for years
Chanel Miller was known only as Emily
doe back in 2015 she was sexually
assaulted after a Stanford University
party Rock Turner a former athlete was
convicted of three felony counts
including assault with intent to rape he
only received a six-month sentence and
that's the low end of state guidelines
well last night on 60 minutes Miller
told Bill Whitaker how she's turning the
trauma into a message of resilience and
she read from her powerful victim impact
statement your damage was concrete
stripped of titles degrees enrollment my
damage was internal unseen the woman
known for years as Emily doe now wants
everyone to know her name you took away
my worth my intimacy my confidence my
own voice until today in 2016
Brock Turner was found guilty of
sexually assaulting Miller she was
discovered unconscious and intoxicated
behind a dumpster on Stanford
University's campus the year before
Miller was rushed to the hospital and
later discovered she had been sexually
assaulted my dream is to write
children's books I felt no parent is
going to want me role model if I'm just
discarded drunk half-naked body behind a
dumpster during the trial the defense
sought to portray Turner as a star
athlete a lot on the line they were
framing it like he had so much to lose
and we're not focusing on what had
already been lost for me Miller was
stunned when California Judge Aaron
Persky sentenced Turner to just six
months in jail now years after her
assault and the painful trial Miller is
reclaiming the narrative of her story
new memoir the defense attorney always
said Chanel has no memory Chanel has no
memory and I remember sitting there and
thinking I will remember everything I
remember the depth of the pain you made
me feel I will remember it and I will
record it and I will write it so that it
will not be lost
she is very impressive and while she
doesn't have any memory the two Swedish
grad students who happen to be riding
their bikes at the time of the assault
zone they have a very vivid memory about
what they saw in fact they intervened on
her behalf
they attacked Brock Turner and held him
on the ground until the police came and
she says without them this story would
have had a very different outcome she
she credits them with changing the
trajectory of their life for of her life
for a while there was a hashtag that
said be the Swede because they intervene
they they basically cursed him out and
held him until the police came don't be
a bystander Steph don't I stand her it's
an amazing amazing story and she's
revealing her face for the first time
conversation does not stop there
tomorrow we will have more from Chanel
Miller tomorrow she will be in studio 57
to talk about the ordeal and how she is
moving forward